Da.
Un quantum circuit o să fie unitatea de valoare
pentru afacerea ta, qubit-ul este unitatea de informație
dar un circuit este unitatea de calcul
deci hai să încercăm să înțelegem ce este un quantum circuit
și să-i analizăm anatomia
uite cum arată un quantum circuit
se descompune în piese — qubit-urile
sunt reprezentate prin aceste linii orizontale, în cazul ăsta reprezentăm
un circuit care are patru qubit-uri, pe care le vedeți
afișate aici; acum gate-urile sunt
modul în care controlăm qubit-urile
și citești gate-urile de la stânga la dreapta
iar gate-urile pe un singur qubit pot fi
gate-uri pe un qubit sau gate-uri pe mai mulți qubit-uri
acolo se vede gate-ul controlat
care este cel cu linia între doi dintre qubit-uri
și acolo o să aibă loc operația de entanglement
și în final ai măsurătoarea și ieșirea clasică
și foarte important — rulezi un circuit de multe ori
ca să obții rezultatul, cu noțiunea de shots
deci un contor de shots care este numărul de ori
în care trebuie să repeți un calcul ca să obții rezultatul
ei bine
cum arată?
hai să vedem cum arată un circuit pe doi biți
ăsta era imaginea de dinainte, nu? — introduce o schimbare de fază
și am arătat înainte o operație care a realizat acea rotație
ce permite să facă operația de interferență
deci hai să facem o comparație între un circuit clasic
și un quantum circuit; într-un circuit clasic ai să
observi că nu vezi luni albastre, nu?
nu există rotații, totul aici este simplu
și ai stările singulare
care în aceste gate-uri sunt cele pe care le vedeai
dar observă ce contrast o să arate
când implementăm efectiv un quantum circuit
acestea sunt circuit-urile reale pe care le rulăm în calculatoarele noastre cuantice
pe care le poți încerca și tu
circuit-urile pe care urmează să le creăm
prin combinarea gate-urilor
generează amplitudinea complexă completă
imaginea pe care v-am arătat-o
mai devreme; de ce este important asta?
pentru că acum putem genera aceste relații complexe
între qubit-uri în termeni de faze
și entanglement și apoi, prin actul măsurătorii,
suntem capabili să colapsăm această cantitate imensă
de calcul care se întâmplă în interior în
un răspuns important
și asta e modul în care ajungem în final la
răspuns; deci le punem alături, doar vizual,
ca să-ți dai seama că un circuit clasic nu poate
exploata niciodată spațiul computațional vast
pe care îl poate un quantum circuit; este
cea mai bună ilustrație care îți dă această intuiție
despre bogăția cu care putem accesa acest spațiu de stări mare.
Și partea frumoasă a acestui lucru este că putem
avea mai multe clase de circuit-uri care
fac funcții diferite; deci
de exemplu, acesta este un circuit
conceput să modeleze riscul financiar
acesta este un exemplu de circuit
folosit pentru probleme de căutare și optimizare
și acesta este un exemplu de circuit folosit pentru a
simula o moleculă; un lucru important
de reținut este că poți proiecta circuit-uri diferite
pentru aplicații diferite
circuit-urile pe care le proiectăm sunt apoi capturate
în software și păstrate ca software
și în cazul nostru le păstrăm în Qiskit
care este kit-ul nostru open source de dezvoltare pentru quantum computing
acesta este unul dintre cele mai utilizate
framework-uri software pentru quantum computing
și îți poți imagina că poți construi
biblioteci de circuit-uri care să fie incluse în
programe clasice care acum combină ce e mai bun din programarea clasică
și ce e mai bun din puterea cuantică